other seeds if you think you want to
keep that Instagram you got that wrong
[ __ ] man
let's discuss okay you've you've said
all what you have to see let me tell you
I ain't said nothing I want to say uh
Angela sit down
it doesn't seem like she's trying to
solve anything Angela and Michael meet
face to face after she ripped his car
apart and attacked him outside of his
house
what a mess yes it was and it's
continuing that's just a goddamn
appetizer mother a nasty one at that
pull up your goddamn phone now Angela is
demanding that Michael give her his
phone for once so I can look at him your
wife let me see it and honestly y'all
after this episode I'm done feeling bad
for Michael I know I've probably said
that before but I'm for real this time
and I'll tell you why then give me the
phone put my pocketbook
oh
you see how simple oh that just fit
chills down my spine
you see how simple let's get into it
okay 90 day fans fam it's melicia I hope
y'all are doing well out there before we
get into the serious business let's
start this recap off with a good laugh
Jenny and submit tried some of the new
moves they learned in the Kama Sutra
class and apparently it costs submit to
get sick to a point where they had to
call a doctor
and I think Danny got too excited while
doing that cowgirl position and she said
on me and my stomach and broke my
stomach yeah uh like a diarrhea I was in
toilet most of the time and I don't want
to do that again
I'm guessing things try the new move
with
[Music]
with you you got injured from it I think
we should file a complaint against the
instructor so make sure you wait people
how heavy or how this video you are
before you try any kind of
yoga positions you should weigh people
first so now you're trying you call me
fat no yes yeah yes you are I'm not
calling you far like I'm calling myself
very skinny
I'm glad Jenny is a good
is a good but yeah gotta love these two
Switching gears
also just to keep you in the loop shaida
received some disappointing news from
her doctor her egg count is low
which means if she and Bilal want to
have a natural childbirth spontaneously
they need to start trying ASAP
you're born with about a million eggs
there's probably about two and a half
percent of those million eggs left
so you know I would definitely say I
would not wait more than six months if
you do want to try to get started and
having a baby because every month your
reserve is going to be going down
the numbers are low and it could hinder
a successful pregnancy of course this
news has shied a emotional and anxious
when I heard Dr mirabile said that my
ovariance reserves were low I felt like
hearing him say that I could never have
children
[Music]
and while below feels for her is always
hard to you know see someone you love
you know um you know trying to get
emotional he doesn't seem to be budging
at the same time
um you know there's a lot that goes into
having the children anybody who has a
child knows that so it's not a matter of
like oh let's just get at it you know
um below
uh
you can't allow fear to hold you back
from making one of your wife's biggest
dreams come true a few episodes ago he
admitted his main concern is that they
will have a baby and shaida will leave
him because that's what happened in his
previous marriage but I'm not his past
that part I understand being cautious
but your future can be better than your
past just because it's happened before
it doesn't mean it has to happen again
who knows this baby could be the best
thing for him right now
foreign
speaking of a blessing
I have one more update for you before we
get into Michael and Angela decided
people
that considered to be decision making
[Music]
Usman takes Kim to meet his mom to get
her blessing for them to get married and
his mom and brothers
they were not having it concerning
Kimberly
I get shocked really I get shook I don't
know why also man like this type of
woman I don't know actually
Kim is the second older white woman he
has brought home things clearly didn't
work out with his ex-wife Lisa plus his
mom wants him to have kids
I mean she literally looks at Kim in
disgust
Ing
we can support this issue what makes it
all worse is that Kim buys his mom a cow
as a gift
I've cut it open eat all the beef take
all the beef out of the salad I don't
care whatever she wants to do it's her
gift but when the cow showed up at the
house his family actually got offended
do you know what I'm thinking
I bribery
it's not a bribe that that is so not a
bride that's what that woman brought a a
sheep or goats oh Osman tried to use the
same trick twice
gotta be smart ER than that they're
probably thinking oh they take us as a
joke
you must think that I'm stupid
now if usman's family ends up taking
that cow
that would be something
can I say something please
may I speak
may I say something please
[Music]
um
to get married anyway
as you can see a lot went down this
episode but now it's time to get into
the biggest must-see moment last night
things got so heated it was like worse
than a nightmare it's the day after
Angela and Michael's confrontation and
she's at her hotel I just changed my
flights and I'll be leaving Nigeria
later today she tells the camera that
the moment she lands in the U.S she's
going to file for divorce and she's
pulling the visas I don't have that much
time before Michael's Visa can be
approved and right now the way Michael's
been acting makes me feel like he's a
damn scammer
I know when I've lost the fight I lost
it and it's time to go home when she
said that I was like
is she really gonna go home
that would be very mature of Angela I
would have been impressed but lo and
behold just when you think she's really
about to leave Nigeria her friend Renee
talks her into having a face-to-face
conversation with Michael and I'll admit
I get her reasoning this is a long way
to come for love we came here for her to
work on her marriage and as her friend
it wouldn't be good if I just let her
leave and she didn't get answers and had
unfinished business no matter what he's
done and I get upset Michael's always
had my feelings in hand you know there's
no sorries no more he's cocky did you
see how he loved the car more than he
loved me
yeah he was pretty pissed and we're in
his car
like he loves social media more than he
loves me
it seems like she's given so much power
to it when social media is not their
main issue it's much deeper than that
why should I keep putting effort all
this energy in trying to change him if
he really just used me for the Visa is
this what you call trying to change him
why should I keep putting effort all
this energy in trying to change him if
he really just used me for the Visa you
can't change somebody you can only
Inspire them to change and nothing about
this is inspirational
stay till tomorrow the next day just
chill anyway Angela decides to stay and
when she gets to the restaurant to meet
with Michael she struts in
literally
once she sits down I don't know if her
nerves started to get the best of her or
what but she throws a shot back cool
meanwhile Michael is in the car outside
the restaurant and it seems as if he's
scared to get out
I don't blame him I've never been so
angry in my life I couldn't sleep until
then I was thinking about everything I'm
shocked and
dumbfounded Angela flew thousands of
miles down to Nigeria all because of
anger
she came here to prove a point at this
moment the only point she's proving is
that our marriage is over
now
wants to believe Michael but
you know what we'll get to him in a
minute let's move on to the part where
they meet face to face
can I get a waitress please
oh can I get a Hello can I get three
shots of vodka and one Heineken at least
three shots Angela are we trying to have
a part two of Last Night
there's already one on the table
three
two each their own Michael's reaction to
her request says it all though is this a
turnip sesh or are we here to talk about
major issues
you gotta talk because you know what you
did let me tell you you don't miss your
wrong you you started I started it
do you take what you've done it's
acceptable yes the man's on Instagram
and he blocked you because you'll be
tripping
excuse my grammar but
text messages oh you're in pain laugh
out loud it's not funny to you you know
the difference between you and I Michael
I have a heart I'm a mean [ __ ] I fight
like goddamn men life you had no heart
man
other seeds If You Think You Gonna Keep
that Instagram you got that wrong [ __ ]
man
you got a wrong [ __ ] man
oh let the man make some money on social
media like you do and allow him to be
free to move as he pleases who wants to
feel like they're in jail in a
relationship Angela's acting like a
warden you got a wrong [ __ ] man
and think about it she's mad off of
assumptions
she's doing all of this because she
thinks Michael is talking to other women
she has no evidence
and no proof let's discuss okay you've
you said all what you have to say I
ain't said nothing I want to say
that's just a goddamn appetizer
Angela said she want me to talk to her
but Angela doesn't listen it's always
about her make us make her happy and do
things in our own way which is not
supposed to be so I'm a husband for kind
of a lot it's not one-sided yeah it can
come off very selfish pull up your
goddamn phone for whoops so I can look
at I'm your wife let me see it Angela
demands that Michael gives her his phone
and she does not let it go you got
[ __ ] in your phone
I want to see everything
what was that
I want to see everything at first I
thought it was a little sexual tension
or something let me see
I want to see everything
your DMs and Instagram but then you just
see Michael retreat
I guess it was a power move that worked
can I see your phone please I don't know
I said no Michael goes on to say that
he's not giving Angela his phone because
he's afraid she's going to break it I'm
lucky she's gonna slam it on the floor
man show you what the whole song we are
not here for that I will definitely show
you but not here then give me the phone
put my [ __ ] look
you see how simple
but right when Angela thought she had
them she
[Music]
got your ass Michael pulls his own slick
move are you gonna hold up talking about
your phone really
leave it just leave me like this goddamn
purse
down this [ __ ]
what is it leave yourself
come on you don't take a genius nobody's
potato on their phone
unless you got something hide no Angela
no at this point let's forget about
Michael and other women y'all
communication sucks
and you have zero respect for him zero
let's address the real issues here I am
not yet to fight I'm not I'm here to
make peace okay
I don't like it
okay this is bad yeah thank you
take my goddamn mouth I am real for you
you're fake to me man that's hard
breaking
I'm gone now come here come on and that
right there is why I am done feeling bad
for Michael
I know feelings are involved and that
can make things complicated but when
it's enough enough yeah we've all been
dumb in relationships and if you think
you haven't you're probably being dumb
in one now
I'm just kidding yeah but when it comes
to Michael it's like having that one
friend who was in a relationship that
they know they have no business being in
and they keep coming to you complaining
about how bad it is
there's a moment where you say okay look
I love you but I am not about to stress
over your unhappiness anymore you're
choosing to stay in something that's not
good for you
I'm getting on my plane nope
you have hurt me
what I've been through with this man is
he worth it
anymore
I'm tired of being strong I'm tired of
being like I gotta not show my emotions
well Angela whether you believe it or
not you are showing your emotions
you definitely are in my opinion all
this just boils down to Angela being
afraid
she's terrified of being vulnerable and
a lot of people are but that doesn't
make it okay for you to lash out and
hurt others instead next week they meet
up again and thankfully it seems like
this time they're actually going to talk
like this I can't trust you you broke
you broke
you were online you know directions a
man like plenty I think both of us make
mistakes well she makes me look like a
bad guy he's sleeping call out the BS
Michael all right 90 day fans fam thanks
for hanging with me make sure you stick
with ET because we are covering it all I
will see you next time
foreign